hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com so we had two very bullish
days on thursday and friday guys on amc
jme jimmy first and on triple q as well
so let's analyze all of that and let's
see what can happen next let's get into
it
alright so amc first
let's just be very you know
methodic
and list every signal that we see so
let's start with
uh rsi rsi above 50 guys
for the first time
here as you can see rsi at 52 the last
time it was about 50 was on april 5th
all right
here when amc was around 18 then we went
to the bearish area below 50 and now we
are back to the um
bullish area bulls are back in control
finally guys
and so this is very good for the rsi
volume uh we have uh volume increasing i
posted an alert
it's not really an alert it's in my amc
recap
i'm sorry i don't post so much guys this
past few days i'm gonna try to post more
uh and i was telling you that the uh the
volume was increasing and that the 13
13.5 level was uh the level we need to
break out above
and then that the resistance will be
14.5 and 17. so we went to the 14.5
level so we have a breakout right above
this trend line
okay
so second good thing third thing we are
above the 20 day moving average okay
it's three good things in terms of
volatility we had a massive move up 18
and we closed at the top of the day it's
very important to close at the top of
the day so that bulls were in full
control during the whole day
so that's all very positive i have
nothing negative to say here uh the only
i mean we can always find resistances
but there's always there are always
going to be resistances on the way up
here the resistance is 14.5
um
i will personally buy on tuesday
probably around the open unless i see a
massive you know up and down for some
reason but it's very very unlikely
probably we're going to open higher or
around the same level uh stop loss
around 12 i know you guys don't like
stop losses but you know i'm just doing
my job here i would use a stop loss
around 12. i personally don't use stop
losses on amc but
uh it's not a good advice to give you so
i give you stop-loss stop-loss level
around 12 below the um the low of friday
so that's it's invalidating what
happened on friday which is exactly what
gave us all these bullish signals so if
this is invalidated all the bullish
signals are not good to use anymore so
this is a good risk reward trade
uh because first we know what we're
looking for we're looking for a squeeze
and even if we're not talking about the
squeeze the next resistance is 17 so
it's already a good risk for tread and
we'll probably uh guys what do you see
here we'll probably go higher because
this might be i say might yes because
for now we don't have all the positive
signals on the rest of the market i'm
going to show you that very soon
one two three four five all right that
would be great and you know once again
guys i give you this waves
you know take it with a grain of salt
all right this is one scenario but this
is a likely scenario to me
uh bam bam bam we can measure the second
wave depth usually around the 61.8 here
is slightly lower as you can see so it's
not the perfect second wave but it's
still acceptable
uh so we might very well have if this
scenario is happening then the third
wave cannot go to 17 right it's too
short compared to the first wave it
needs to go at least to 20. so let's see
if we're able to do that and you know
guys what we are really looking for but
for that we would need the rest of the
market to be bullish as well we are
looking for squeeze guys uh so we are
looking for breakout above this blue
trend line all right so the level right
now last time it was 32 in march this
time is lower which is good about this
descending trend lines
uh now it's around 26 27 right so maybe
we're gonna have a third wave going
there a false wave pullback and maybe a
fifth going here i don't know guys this
would be very very nice uh but for now
we don't have all the positive signals
on the rest of the market which we need
for squeeze to happen because i remind
you guys for squeeze to happen we need
everybody to buy everybody asset
managers hedge funds to get the short we
need all of them to buy and retail
investors of course apes in the trade so
um
for now we don't have all these signals
but let's you know just have some fun
and imagine what could happen this is a
likely scenario to me and this is very
much looking like a third wave
third waves are the ones with the
greatest volume so once again if this is
the third wave we should have a massive
move up next week so
let's monitor all of that once again
stop loss 12 guys if
we go below that this invalidates this
scenario jamie
uh gme guys was the one triggering
everything once again with the release
of its crypto last week here i have
already prepared everything for you guys
bam you can measure the first wave so
let's let's first count the waves
so bam bam bam here one two
three four five all right maybe
something like that
we're gonna find out very soon but this
looks very much to me like a third wave
and here when you measure
the first wave
and you you check the retracement we
went to the 61.8 slightly with some
excess but not on a daily close
so this looks very much like a second
wave we have earnings coming here if
earnings are good guys this will be one
more catalyst to uh for bulls to use to
you know buy more and for shorts to
maybe cover
um
so next resistances are
so 140 as you can see we
closed just below that level uh this is
the first resistance as you can see it
was the um
the lower band of this consolidation
here to know where the resistances and
the supports guys just focus on
consolidation all right so here res and
add moving averages 20 50 to 100 on a
daily four hours time frame the most
used ones so here the 200-day moving
average is at 152 so the next resistance
to me is a 152 and if we close above
that probably we're gonna go to the 200
level quickly so once again
you know no guarantee of course it's
just one scenario there are some various
scenarios too but right now it's looking
great guys 130 is the support level um
next support is 105 but if we get back
there we're going to lose the momentum
we have here very bullish rsi at 61. so
bulls are in full control uh we had you
know some consolidation here just with
the market took a breath on low volume
nothing very
big so here the british momentum is
definitely here on amc and jamie all the
bullish signals are here
we have some resistances above but so we
might see some pullbacks all right it's
possible but
booze and control and you know the
probability we go higher is just higher
than the property we go over that's a
fact that technical analysis
now
for that once again to happen guys
uh i've added triple q in my daily
updates
almost daily uh because i know that uh
because it's very important for
everybody to be in the trade and asset
managers headstands they follow that so
if they
if if the whole market is not bullish
you know they're not gonna buy inc and
gme that's a fact so uh here
we are i'm monitoring that for quite
some time guys and uh we have finally
the breakout above the above my trend
line as you can see i'm connecting one
two three four uh reactions and here we
have a breakout all right
above the trend line above the 20 moving
average the rsi just came in the
positive territory the bullish uh
territory 15
50.8
so it's not a lot but it's bullish we
had a bullish divergence here market
packing logo lows momentum making high
highs so momentum with us um
rsi with us
breakout with us
we crossed the 20 day moving average we
closed at the top of the day so i mean
this is bullish what do we miss guys
what do we miss you know what we miss we
miss the volume so does it mean that we
are not bullish it doesn't mean that we
are bullish we are bullish here
uh i'm gonna buy on tuesday different
things i'm gonna post in this code i'm
not posting right now because as you can
see guys i'm well dressed it's my mom my
mom's birthday uh we're gonna go to
restaurant very soon i'm doing this very
quickly for you guys
um
and tomorrow i'm gonna you know look
for breakouts and for nice opportunities
to give you with stop losses because
guys there is still a lot of uncertainty
i don't see for now all the problems
that have been solved inflation war all
of that is still here we can still have
a bull market but
uh here we don't have the volume but
once again you saw we have volume and
amcgme why don't we have the volume here
because triple q is an etf and an etf
trades more an index when there is fear
so on the way down
so it's acceptable not to have a big
volume increase on the way up
but
the problem i have
this is the usual reasoning but usually
we have this situation strong volume on
the way down and then a breakout so of
course it's difficult to trade more than
when there is so much fear but look what
happened guys we consolidated we had the
low volume which was a good news i told
you guys it's very good to have low
volume on the way down and this is the
reason why i was starting to i
personally uh took profit on my short
position here i reopened one here and
got stopped here 500 usd loss in my new
um
protection trade it's nothing compared
to the rest of my portfolio so i'm very
happy to take this loss and uh right now
i'm gonna i'm still having a short
position triple q i'm gonna reduce
slowly um but once again yeah we had
this uh low volume here and whenever you
have the low volume during the
consideration then you should have an
increase in volume so that it shows that
buyers are back in the game here
i'm sorry guys buyers are not here not
on triple q so they here on amc they're
here on gme but on the rest of the
market it's not looking good cryptos i'm
not gonna make uh an update about
bitcoin and ethereum here they're not
looking good two guys so we don't have
everything that is bullish in this
market all right so
um maybe we're gonna have a global
market that is you know stable or not
very bullish and a run-up on the mcgme
true possible but if we're looking for a
squeeze you guys know that we need the
global market to be very bullish too so
that everybody is in the trade so here
to conclude uh we are bullish definitely
but it's not perfect i'm still gonna buy
but tight stop loss here
a trade idea is to buy you know around
the open on monday on tuesday probably
you know around 309 310 something like
that
uh stop loss roughly
you know below the 61.8 so it depends
how high we go
we need to adjust that level but we're
actually below 280 let's call it here
289 all right so if triple q goes below
289 this invalidates everything guys and
probably better gonna take back control
so let's monitor that let's uh let's see
what can happen here but guys it's been
a long time things were not looking so
good i hope it's gonna hold i don't know
of course guys um
but i'm personally gonna increase my
position in meme stocks mcgme and i'm
gonna reduce my short position on triple
two this is what i'm doing not financial
advice
uh once again guys this is the kind of
situation i could tell you stay close to
shore so thank you very much for
watching this video and if you did enjoy
this video don't forget to click on the
sub like and the bell button guys so
that you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show guys see you soon